I'm very excited for Twilight Zone
thank you very one stress I am too very
excited where are you in the development
process of this what can you tease
people where we are as we are almost
starting on production of the first
season so we're weeks away from
production on Episode one of the first
season as we go and in a television show
you're developing as you're shooting so
you know we have a few episodes that I'm
already written and done ready to be
shot and then we have episodes that are
outlined and then we have episodes that
are just pitches at this point and
television season goes those things get
filled out so we're starting off soon
and it's Jordan Peele from get out and
from key and Peele and myself as a guy
producers and I guess overseeing the
process and having a great time doing it
we have an amazing group of writers and
it's gonna be fun because a lot of
actors that want to be in it while it's
because it's anthology series well you
can be a movie star and sign on for you
know an eighth week in a day rather um
commitment and you're the star of a
trailer's own episode and we look at
something like Black Mirror obviously is
not just a competition but the
inspiration and we want to do something
that's cool and different and edgy and
like the original show has social
relevance and so it is something that is
socio-political and tackles big themes
but in fun science-fiction genre way
it's the same way get out - how many
episodes is the first season that I
can't say do you have any of you booked
your all your directors or still coming
together so coming together but we've
booked a lot of them I'm very excited